congratulations on this movie it's
really good abigail let's start with you
first i mean angel goes through so much
in this movie so much no wonder she's
not open to
real love at the beginning when she sees
it um what was it like for you just
getting into this character
um
yeah you know i think i just had to kind
of
dive in i
i did as much research as i could on on
the topic at hand and
talked to some women actually in in
angel's position
which was very eye-opening and
gave me
a lot of
insight
and um
i mean
even more respect than i already had
it was
you know i i felt uh
still feel a huge responsibility to this
story and to this role
so
i you know i hope i i hope i do it
justice um
not only for the fans but for you know
women
in angel's
position
but it was uh yeah i definitely did a
lot of a lot of preparation and um
a lot of late nights
studying and worrying and
yeah in my head but then you know once
you get there and once you
show up on the day you just you have to
like let it go and hope for the best but
yeah well you were so good in this so no
worries
the performance is so great you know
your performance is awesome too it's
pretty cool seeing you play a mom what
was it like for you playing this role um
it was like a little blast from the past
my first ever job i was a mom on
degrassi i played a teen mom yeah
yeah so
it didn't feel too unfamiliar um but it
was a very very different genre and a
very different environment this is a
period piece
um i i played a woman
in a time that was very very difficult
for women to live in yeah because they
didn't have a lot of freedom they didn't
have a lot of choices
and despite all that my character in the
film did her very very very best to be
the best mother that she could and do
whatever it takes
to survive and for the the well-being of
her child
and unfortunately she's dealt a pretty
horrible hand and
i don't want to spoil anything but some
things happen and it's pretty tragic
yeah so there's so many elements of this
that you know are so sad these
characters especially both of your
characters go through so much but at the
heart of this film there is this
beautiful
love story there is romance there so i
wanted to know
how romantic do you think you are in
real life on a scale of one to ten do
you feel like you embrace the romance
side
yeah for sure
i mean we're we're girls we're women
i think that's in in our dna when we
come out of the womb like there's
romance is already
ingrained
yeah yeah i like that how do you show
like like i was talking to eric and he
said he loves to give gifts what's like
your your way of showing love i'm more
of an acts of service and
a physical touch person i like to do
little things for my significant other
and i like to receive like if i'm having
a stressful day and
can't get everything done if my partner
walks the dog for me like that's the
greatest
gift i can get and everything ever
yeah
i love the abigail what about you
i don't know if i would consider myself
like romantic if i'm being honest i like
i love
love stories
i love
love
um
but in my
personal life i don't know like i i just
i'm not like the biggest romantic i'm
very
um
i don't know logical
yeah i know i get that you get wrapped
up in it
boring yeah i don't know
uh yeah but like i or maybe i'm so
romantic that i'm
cynical i don't know
i definitely like my favorite stories
are love stories
so that's a little bit contradicting i
don't know i need to probably look more
into that no no i like that that's
awesome
therapy
um
no i uh
my
yeah mine are acts of service and then
words of affirmation yeah that's
important too and just to wrap things up
nina was so cute hearing your man sean
talk about hey you're a lifesaver during
lockdown do you feel the same way about
him
yeah he's pretty incredible pretty
special human being for sure i love it
you get nervous watching him perform
uh you mean watching him risk his life
yeah
uh yeah a little bit a little bit but
he's the best of the best at what he
does so at the same time i i have to
nervously sit back and make and you know
have confidence that he'll do what he
does yeah well i love that uh guys so
nice getting to talk to congratulations
on this movie
thank you so much thank you bye guys